thank you everyone for checking out this
talk today we'll be discussing improve
in approximability results for VC
Dimension and little Stones dimension
let's start by reviewing a few important
definitions
given a domain x a concept is simply a
Boolean function on the domain X
and a concept class is just a set of
Concepts
throughout this work we consider a
concept class as being represented
explicitly as a Boolean metric where the
number of columns is equals to The
Domain size and the number of rows is
equals to the number of Concepts denoted
by m here
an example of concept class is that of
threshold here the domain X consists of
real numbers and each concept has a
threshold denoted by I here
such that the concept evaluates on X to
1 even only if x is uh no smaller than
the threshold
for example if our domain X is one two
three then we could have four Concepts
here where the first concept is all one
and so on and so forth
next let's recall the definition of BC
Dimension and for that we have to start
with uh shattering
we say that a subset s of the domain X
is shatter
if when we restrict the concept class on
just this subset s
then it contains all the two to the size
of s distinct functions on S
just to give you an example here if we
look at the
threshold on the right here and really
stick on the set where s is just one
then this set is shatter because both
one and zero occurs but if we look at
the set that is one and two it is not
shatter because one zero doesn't occur
in the restriction
the VC Dimension is then defined as the
maximum size of shutter set
in the crease of threshold the VC
Dimension is just one
now the importance of VC Dimension is
that it determines the sample complexity
in the probably approximately correct
learn or packed learning model up to a
constant Factor since we will not be
using the pack model directly here we
will skip the definition for brevity
next let us consider the second
dimension in the title of this talk the
little Stones dimension
and while there is a combinatorial
definition of the little Stone Dimension
we will not use it in this talk so we
will instead use the definition based on
online learning
so the setting of online learning is as
follow
it runs in iterations and in each
iteration I the algorithm receives some
x i in the domain X
upon receiving this x i the algorithm
has to predict y2.i
after this prediction the algorithm then
get to see the true label y i
go on the online learning algorithm is
to make as few mistakes in the
predictions as possible
the guarantee that we have is that all
the x i and the true level y i are all
consistent with some unknown Concept in
the class C
the little Stone Dimension is then the
optimal mistake bound among the base
online learner with respect to worst
possible sequences
now there is one important online
learning algorithm that is generic and
we'll be using later so let me state
that here this is the so-called housing
algorithm
so the algorithm works as follows we
keep a candidate set of Concepts that so
far agree with all the examples x i y i
that we have seen
whenever we receive a new x i we
consider the two possible prediction
zero and one these two possible
prediction
partition the class of candidate into
two sets based on whether the true value
is zero or one then we predict the one
that agree with at least half of the
candidates
what this mean is that each time we make
a mistake we rule out at least half of
the candidate Concepts
and this means that the mistake bound
that we get is at most log of the size
of the concept and this also implies
that the little Stone dimension of any
concept class is at most the log of the
size of the concept class
although of course in some cases there
are smarter algorithms and a little
Stone Dimension can be much smaller
all right so with those definitions in
mind let's State the computational
questions that we are interested in here
the questions are as simple as it gets
we are given a concept class C as
explicitly as an M times x metric and we
want to compute its VC Dimension or its
little Stone dimension
here we will use little n to denote the
size of the input which is as M times x
now there are a few useful observations
as I stated earlier in the previous
Slide the little Stone Dimension is
Atmos log of M where m is the size of
the concept class
and it's also not hard to verify that
the VC Dimension is no more than the
little Stone dimension
so what this means is that we can
actually use a certain Brute Force
algorithm to compute the little Stone
Dimension and the VC Dimension exactly
in into the order of log in time
furthermore there is also a trivia
algorithm that run in polynomial time
and give a lock-in approximation
essentially we can just output one on
any non-trivial concept class
we can also get a trade-off between the
two if we use some sort of limited Brute
Force where if we run in into the P time
we can get some log in divided by P
approximation algorithm
so why are this interesting
one of the more interesting thing here
is that since we have an entry order of
log n time exact algorithm for these
problems they are unlikely to be NP hard
as otherwise
all the NP complete problems will be
solvable in quasi polynomial time
this means that to prove harness for
these problems we need stronger
complexity assumptions than just P
naught equals to NP
one complexity assumption we will be
using is the exponential time hypothesis
or eth
which states that no 2 to the liter of n
time algorithm can solve three set
exactly where n denotes the number of
variables
we will also be using a strengthening of
this hypothesis called Gap EDH which
says that in the same running time no
algorithm can even distinguish between a
satisfiable three-set formula and one
that is not 99 satisfiable
we will also be using complexity
assumptions based on the planted click
problem so let's recall that problem
quickly here
there are two distributions of Interest
here the first is G and a half which is
just the uniform distribution overall n
vertex graphs
the second distribution is the one where
we first got T from t n and a half
and then on top of it randomly plan a
click of size k
the goal of the planet click problem is
then to distinguish between these two
cases
so for the pendant click problem there
is a trivial end to the order of login
time algorithm this is because in the GN
and a half case the maximum click style
is at most order of login
so we can enumerate through all the
click of size
order of login if we find one then we
know that we are in the second case
furthermore when K is large enough in
particular if K is order of square root
n then the problem becomes solvable in
polynomial time using spectral method
the planted click hypothesis or PCH
states that this spectral algorithm is
essentially the best possible in the
sense that if K is little or of square
root n
then the pandemic problem is not
solvable in polynomial time
recently there is also an extension of
this hypothesis called a strong dead
click hypothesis or SPCA
which states that if K is polynomial a
small polynomial in n
then planted click is not solvable and
enter a little of log in time
which means that essentially The Brute
Force algorithm is the best out the best
possible that we can do in that case
okay so these are the four complexity
assumptions
that we'll be using in this world
let us now State the previous result and
then our result
the first result on these problems was
proven by public
in 1993 they show that Computing VC
Dimension exactly is complete for the
class called log NP we will not be using
this class
here so I will not Define it but it is
essentially a limited non-determinism
version of NP that corresponds to this
into the login time algorithms
a few year letters
fences and Litman show that Computing
little Stone Dimension exactly
is log NP hard although they did not
show that this problem is contained in
log NP
a consequence here is that if we assume
the exponential time hypothesis then
there is no end to the little of log n
time algorithm for computing the VC
Dimension or little Stones Dimension
exactly
in other words The Brute Force algorithm
that we discussed earlier in this talk
is the best possible for exactly
Computing these dimensions
this hardness results have been extended
recently by myself and obvious
to approximation algorithms in
particular we show assuming eth
that there is no end to the little or
tilde of log in time algorithm that can
approximate VC Dimension to within any
Factor less than two
for little Stones dimension
we get a slightly weaker result whether
in approximability ratio is only
slightly larger than one
why these are good initial in
approximately results they still live
quite a few problems open
for example there could still be a
polynomial time constant Factor
approximation for VC Dimension or little
Stones dimension
in this work we provide several new in
approximate Mobility results that grow
out such approximation algorithm
for example assuming Gap ETS or
strongish pendant click hypothesis we
can show that no polynomial time
algorithm can get little or log n
approximation for VC Dimension or little
Stones dimension
and this approximation ratio is tight
because recalling from earlier that
there is a trivial polynomial time log
in approximation algorithm for both
dimensions
while this result only rule out
polynomial time algorithm we also
provide result that
get the tight running time lower bound
as well in particular assuming the
strong is planted click hypothesis we
can show that no end to the little of
log in time algorithm can get constant
Factor approximation for these
dimensions
finally we also have
quite a few additional results that are
in between these two results
for example for Gap EDS instead of
getting the tight running time low bound
of enter the leader of log n we only get
n to a little of log n to the one third
there are many more uh results of this
form that are not completely tight but I
would not be stating them here
all right so those are The quick summary
of our results
let me now discuss how we prove these
results
and as the title of our paper suggests
we are proving this result we are a
reduction from the by click problem
so in the by click problem we are given
a Viper type graph and an integer k
the goal is to determine whether there
is a by click or complete by patite
graph
that has K vertices from the a site and
K word c is from the B side
for example if this is our input
appetite graph and our case equals to 2
then we may pick these last two vertices
for a and these last two vertices for B
and they would induce this balance by
click
it would be convenient also to consider
the Gap version of by click when stating
the hardness results in particular in
the Gap version we want to distinguish
between the yes case where the graph D
contains a by click of size K1 and in
the node case the graph T doesn't
contain even a by click of size K2 where
K2 is much less than K1
as the title of this talk suggests
we are not actually going to be using
this balance version of by click problem
directly
instead we'll be using what we call the
exponential by click problem
so the setting is
exactly the same as before except that
while we are still asking for K vertices
on the B side we are now asking for 2 to
the K over this is on the a side
like for example if K is equals to 2
here then we would want to Output four
vertices on the ASI and just two
vertices on the B side
again we can Define the
Gap version of this exponential by click
correspondingly where in the yes case we
should have this 2 to the K1 and K1 by
click and in the no case the input graph
doesn't even contain 2 to the K2 and K2
by click
so let us note here that there is a
trivial reduction from by click to the
exponential by click problem which we'll
be using
in particular if we have the Gap by
click hardness where in the yes case the
gravity contains 2 to the K1 size
balance by click and in no case it
doesn't even contain K2 by click
then this immediately imply the k1k to
Gap exponential by click problem
by just keeping the same graph and this
follow immediately from the definition
note however that we will need a pretty
large gap in the original Gap by click
problem
so this brings us next to the main
reduction
our main reduction in this paper is a
reduction from The Gap exponential by
click problem
to the
problem that we call Gap VC Dimension
and little Stone dimension
which is stated as follows so we are
given a concept class C and we want to
distinguish between the yes case where
the VC dimension of the input Class C is
at least D1
and in no case where the little Stone
Dimension is less than D2 and here again
D1 is a parameter that is larger than D2
now recall here that the
little Stone Dimension is always at
least the VC dimension
this means that a hardness of this D1 D2
Gap we see little Stone Dimension
problem immediately imply hardness
for approximating for both the VC
Dimension and the little Stone Dimension
at once in particular if we can prove
the hardness of this Gap problem then
there can be no D1 over D2 approximation
algorithm for these dimensions
this is another interesting aspect of
our work because I will require just a
single reduction whereas in the previous
work there has to be separate reductions
for VC Dimension and little Stone
dimensions in terms of the exact
parameter we can get the yes case in our
VC and little Stone Dimension to have
Dimension at least K1 over 2 and the
Nokia is to have little Stone Dimension
less than 2 times K2 where K1 and K2 are
the parameters from The Gap exponential
by click so this gave a hardness
approximation for VC Dimension and
little Stone dimension of approximation
ratio K1 over 4 times K2 so in other
words we only lose a factor of 4 in the
hardness of approximation from this
reduction from The Gap exponential by
click problem
with the main reduction in mind let me
now quickly describe the overall
framework that we use to get all the
different hardness results that I have
stated earlier in this talk
so many previous papers have already
studied the balance version of bike
league and even though here we require
the Gap to be quite large where in the
yes case it has to be exponentially
larger and no case it turns out that
many of these results still apply for
such a large gap
so we can get the hardness for Gap
balance by click directly
and then using the trivial reduction we
talked about a couple slides ago we can
go from this to a hardness for Gap
exponential by click
and then we apply our main reduction
which then give the harness for
approximating VC Dimension or little
Stone dimension
so this is the entire framework so while
I will not be stating all the
instantiations of this result and all
this parameter let me show you one
example just to get a feeling of how
such a framework can be applied
in particular in this example we start
from Shalom took as our result which say
that assuming Gap eth
there is no polynomial time algorithm
for Gap by click
where in the yes case there is a by
click of size n to the leader of one and
in no case there is a by click of size
Omega 1.
so using the trivial reduction we
discussed earlier we get the hardness of
Gap by click where in the yes case the
K1 is
little of log n and K2 is Omega of 1.
so from this we apply the main reduction
so we get that the Gap we see little
Stone Dimension is also hard for
polynomial time algorithm where the yes
case the D1 is little of log n and in no
case the D2 is Omega of 1.
and that's it this immediately give us
that assuming WTH there is no polynomial
time algorithm that give little or block
n approximation algorithm for VC
Dimension a little Stone Dimension which
is our type in approximability hardness
result
with that example done we will now get
back to our main reduction and see how
it works
let us start with a simple attempt and
this is perhaps
the most natural reduction there is
which is just to take the concept class
to be the adjacency metric of the input
graph G for the exponential by click
problem for example if this is our input
graph G then we just write down its
adjacent symmetric and this is our
concept class
note here that now each vertex
from the side a now becomes a concept
whereas each vertex on the side B
becomes a domain element
so let's see whether this reduction
works
and let's start with the soundness of
the reduction
to do this let's recall very quickly the
helping algorithm recall that this is
the algorithm where we keep a set of
candidate concept
that agree with all the examples so far
and we try to predict in such a way that
if we are wrong then at least half of
the candidate Concepts will be ruled out
and this gives the bound of log of the
concept size on the mistake bound
okay with that in mind how do we use
this halving algorithm to prove the
soundness of this reduction
just to quickly recall in the soundness
proof the goal here is to show that if
the input graph G doesn't contain 2 to
the K2 K2 by click then the little Stone
dimension of the resulting concept class
should be less than 2 times K2
so to show that the little Stone
Dimension is small it suffice to give a
learning algorithm with small mistake
bound
so how does our learning algorithm work
the learning algorithm Works in two
phrases
in the first phase
will always predict zero
we keep doing this until we make k2
mistakes
once we make k2 mistake we switch to use
the housing algorithm that we just
discussed
now how can we analyze uh the mistake
bound of this algorithm
obviously if we never reached the second
stage it means that we make less than K2
mistakes so we are done already so we
only have to consider the case where we
reach the second stage which means that
we make k2 mistakes in the first stage
so if we make k2 mistakes in this first
stage what does it tell us
so let's think about this for a moment
if you make k2 mistakes in the first
stage since we always predict zero it
means that the true concept class has to
predict one
so what this means is that if we take a
look
at the graph induced by the set of the
remaining candidates
and the elements that we make mistakes
on in the first stage then it must
induce a buy click
and since we assume that there is no 2
to the K2 and K2 by click and we already
make k2 mistakes meaning that there are
already K2 elements on the side B in the
mistake set
then we have that the candidates it must
be of size less than 2 to the K2
in other words once we reach the second
stage the candidate said that we are
left with has size less than 2 to the K2
but this means that since we are using
the halving algorithm we will be making
at most
K2 mistakes in the second stage
so in total the number of mistakes that
we make is less than 2 times K2
and that's it that's the entire
soundness proof so so far so good
how about the completeness
so what do we want to prove again in the
completeness we want to show that if G
contains a lash by click a 2 to the K1
K1 by click
then the VC dimension of the resulting
concept class C has to be at least K1
unfortunately as you might have noticed
this is actually not true a simple
halter example here is when G is the
complete bipartite graph
in this case the resulting metric C is
the R1 metric so its VC Dimension is
just zero
now the issue here seems to be that
there are in some sense too many ones in
the metric C so how do we fix this
so in the final reduction instead of
taking the adjacency metric of the graph
T directly
we start by first removing each edge of
T randomly with probability 0.5
independently
and then after that we then take C to be
the adjacency metric of this modified
graph
it turns out that the sound is proof
goes exactly as before
and in the completeness uh proof it's
also not hard to argue that with high
probability the VC dimension of the
resulting class is now
lash at least K1 over 2.
so that's it that's the final reduction
very simple and that's also all the high
level ideas of the proof so with that
let me conclude here
we provide several new hardness or
approximation results for VC Dimension
and little Stones I mentioned
for example we can get the tight
approximation ratio
assuming Gap EDH or strong expanded
click hypothesis we rule out little of
log in approximation algorithm in
polynomial time we can also get tight
running time lower Bound for example we
rule out assuming strong each pendantly
hypothesis any constant Factor
approximation algorithm will enter a
little of log in time and we also
provide many other results in between
these two as well
nonetheless there are still quite a few
open problems
recall that the VC Dimension itself is
log NP complete while the little Stone
Dimension is log NP hard
so one might wonder whether it's
possible whether we can prove log NP
hardness or approximation for these
results and that remains an interesting
open problem
another problem that I sort of touched
upon a little bit earlier is that the
little Stone Dimension is not known to
be contained in the class log NP so it
would be interesting to show such a
containment or Define a new class or
identify a new class for which little
Stones I mentioned is complete for
all right and that's it for this talk
thank you all very much for your
attention thank you